very important information the CDC says
more than 600 people die in the US every
year from extreme heat our doctor Tara
Narula joins us at the table with more
on this so Tara there are three stages
to heat emergency what are the warning
signs in the body and then what are the
precautions people can take to protect
themselves right so really what happens
is your body's temperature control
system becomes overwhelmed we have in
our brain an area that controls our
temperature pretty pretty finely so that
we keep it within ninety eight point six
degrees plus or minus two degrees but
the problem is when you start to climb
up to over 104 you become at risk for
heatstroke
so heatstroke is when your core
temperature is 104 or higher and you
start to have central nervous system
dysfunction at those higher temperatures
basically your cells start to breakdown
your gut becomes leaky you risk muscle
damage kidney liver brain damage and
even heart damage and really the
mechanisms that the body normally has is
that we basil dilate we dilate those
blood vessels in our skin so that we
shunt blood to the skin to basically
radiate off the heat and also we sweat
and so the sweat evaporates and that
cools us the problem is when the
temperature is so high it doesn't work
that mechanism and also when the
humidity is high we can't evaporate the
sweat off as efficiently I wasn't
walking yesterday it scary part of this
is sometimes you don't quite know how
bad it's gotten right till it's too late
right so muscle cramping or heat
cramping is kind of the beginning stages
then heat exhaustion and then heat
stroke and some of the warning signs
would be things like a faster heart rate
feeling nausea or vomiting or having a
headache or fatigue or also starting to
become confused delirious agitated and
then ultimately you can have loss of
consciousness and this is a real medical
emergency so if you see someone
suffering you need to call 911 and start
to cool them by any mechanism you can
get them into a cool bath put cool
sponges or you know cool blankets on
them really try to get their temperature
down to at least 101 to 102 and this is
for you Gail this is what my daughter
it's an accessory bracelet accessory so
she knows about my hot flashes fabulous
although you might need a bigger fan